the Laffer Curve is an interesting story
the first evidence that we have of it in
the public sphere is from 1978 when his
good friend at the Wall Street Journal
Jude winiski published it in a magazine
called the public interest as an excerpt
of his book of that year called the way
the world works and within that book of
1978 Jude winiski says I have a great
story to tell you guys about 1974 four
years prior and that is my good friend
Arthur Laffer sketched on a napkin for
Donald Rumsfeld the chief of staff of
the Ford Administration and the chief of
staff knows everything about the
president not the president surprised
his chief of staff by announcing whip
inflation now which is a five percent
tax surcharge on incomes much like
Lyndon Johnson actually accomplished and
Don Rumsfeld was keeping a stiff upper
lip there and we were talking about this
policy at dinner and that's when I said
you know with a five percent tax
surcharge the one thing you will not get
is you will not get five percent more
Revenue but there's also a good
likelihood you'll get less revenues as
well and that's where I took the napkin
and Drew the curve in explicit response
to a policy a proposal that never got
passed
the Mythic nature of the Laffer Curve is
absolutely essential to its existence
and its nature if we might try to
imagine hard as it might be what
conditions were when the Laffer Curve
took off like a rocket within popularity
in the 1970s there was a 10 12 year
period before and after of incredible
price inflation 10 per year eight
percent per year 14 per year and the
official response of government was it's
unsolvable so it was essential in that
context for somebody to step out of
economics and say I have something here
that's not in the journals that's not
from official them because these people
have all said it's impossible you needed
something counter-cultural and unique
like a curve on the napkin that the
public would say yeah we're going to
storm the Tower with this so you get
more labor more investment more growth
less tax avoidance and revenues go up
this is an argument that drives the left
crazy and the Laffer Curve has been
insulted and derided and whatnot it has
outlined everybody
it's still I think the hottest ticket in
economics today I mean Robert Schiller
the statistical Economist at Yale says
that not only has the Laffer Curve been
more discussed in popular conversation
than any other economic curve of modern
times it also was discussed from after
1978 as much as any major popular
cultural phenomenon and he specifically
Compares it to the Rubik's Cube Rubik's
Cube was about the biggest thing going
in toys and popular chit chat in the
early late 70s early 80s and Schiller
says people talked about the Laffer
Curve he counted the hits in the media
as much as the Rubik's Cube so I think
the Laffer card on the napkin no matter
how well it was worked out in
mathematics beforehand and its
mathematics is impeccable we have the
full evidence of that from 1973 it had
to be drawn on a curve for the public to
Rally to it